you are particularly sensitive to drugs
and are you a sensitive to alcohol as
you are well I'm a such a lightweight
like the first time I ever got drunk I
was 16 and I was with my parents of
course and I had like half a Rolling
Rock and then I immediately yelled at my
dad I'm funnier than you and my mom was
the nurse practitioner I was like I was
like mom what's going on with
breastfeeding you got to tell people to
stop it it's weird half a Rolling Rock
yeah that's it and I became very
belligerent
and evidently like anti basic maternal
care yeah have you had a lot of medical
procedures in your life have you I mean
if you hired Salman sir yeah I mean my
body is always in a state of like very
gradual but noticeable decay and I got I
recently got a stress fracture in my
foot from doing a vocal warmup no you
did I swear I didn't talking about I did
a vocal warmup to prepare to act were
you like your squat down and you try to
get your resonators working and just the
mere pressure of like shifting my body
weight caused my bone to break sorry I'm
sorry
that's just so that's so sad I went to
the doctor and he was like he was like
did you get this like oh were you like
running on concrete or did you do like
p90x CrossFit kind of stuff and I was
like no I was just exploring my pelvic
floor yeah I have a similar thing I was
super tall and thin and I felt like it's
just not the when I was younger I was
like six 450 pounds and I realized I
wasn't built for the earth not yet to
live were you the same way like Italy I
got I remember the first time I had back
pain I was like finally because I've had
the personality of someone who has back
pain my whole life
now I had the physical malady yeah good
good yeah it's all coming together
exactly
you